Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The education of a boy, wrote the Greek historian Herodotus about the Persians, will begin at the age of five and finish when he is 20. But in all that time, he will only ever be taught three things, how to ride a horse, how to fire a bow, and how to tell the truth. Well, the thesis of today's episode of the rest is history is that actually the persians taught a lot more than that actually in fact that huge amounts today even in the 21st century here in the west that we take for granted that it derives
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。希腊历史学家希罗多德在谈到波斯人时写道，一个男孩的教育从五岁开始，到二十岁结束。但在整个过程中，他只会被教导三件事：如何骑马、如何射箭以及如何说真话。好吧，今天这期《历史的余味》的论点是，实际上波斯人教的东西远不止这些。事实上，即使在21世纪的今天，我们在西方视为理所当然的许多事物，其根源都
ultimately from persia and i guess this is a thesis that may not seem immediately obvious because the persians don't really tend to occupy the kind of outsized role that other ancient civilizations do in the popular imagining civilizations like the Egyptians or the Greeks or the Romans. But speaking for myself, the more I've studied antiquity, written about it, thought about it, the more I've come to think that Persia is like some great kind of underground spring from which infinite numbers of rivers and streams, when you trace them back over the course of the centuries and the millennia, turn out to have sprung from. Dominic, as a modern historian,
最终可以追溯到波斯。我想这个论点可能看起来并不显而易见，因为在人们的想象中，波斯人似乎并不像埃及人、希腊人或罗马人那样，在古代文明中占据那种超然的地位。但就我个人而言，我对古代史研究得越多、写得越多、思考得越多，就越觉得波斯就像一股伟大的地下泉水，当你追溯几个世纪甚至几千年的历史时，会发现无数的河流和小溪都是从这里发源的。多米尼克，作为一名现代历史学家，
I don't know whether you would accept that. I mean, I guess even the Iranian revolution of 1979 slightly plays that role, doesn't it? I think it absolutely does, Tom. I think actually when you... We in the West sort of tend to forget a little bit about Iran, and particularly we're fixated in the 20th century on Russia and China, I suppose, as the sort of antagonists of the West. But Iran, the Iranian revolution of 1979 seems to me one of the great foundational moments of the contemporary era. So it's the moment that, you know, the rise of the Ayatollahs, of radical Islam, and then the way in which that was exported. And Iran's sort of status as, you know, I mean,
我不知道你是否会接受这一点。我的意思是，我想即使是1979年的伊朗革命也稍微扮演了这样的角色，不是吗？我认为确实如此，汤姆。实际上，当我们在西方……我们有点倾向于忘记伊朗，特别是在20世纪，我们把目光锁定在俄罗斯和中国身上，把它们视为西方的某种对立面。但伊朗，1979年的伊朗革命在我看来是当代最伟大的奠基时刻之一。那是阿亚图拉崛起、激进伊斯兰教兴起，以及随后这种思潮向外输出的时刻。而伊朗的地位，你知道，我的意思是，
Iran talks of the United States as the great Satan, but in many ways Iran has been the great Satan, hasn't it, for the secular West ever since 1979. Yeah, and I think that for lots of people, if you say Iran, you tend to think of women shrouded in black veils and old men with long beards wagging their fingers and saying, yeah, to America.
伊朗称美国为“大撒旦”，但在许多方面，自1979年以来，伊朗对于世俗的西方来说一直就是那个“大撒旦”，不是吗？是的，而且我认为对于很多人来说，如果你提到伊朗，你往往会想到蒙着黑色面纱的女性，以及留着长胡子、摇着手指对美国说“不”的老人。
And perhaps that can obscure the way in which Persia is one of the truly great, rich civilizations of the world. Yeah, I buy that. I buy that. We have someone I'm sure will agree with that somebody actually knows about it absolutely ali ansari who is um a professor of iranian studies at saint andrews university no less author of very short introduction to iran ali thanks so much for coming
也许这掩盖了波斯作为世界上真正伟大、丰富的文明之一的事实。是的，我认同这一点。我认同。我们有一位肯定会同意这一点的人，他对此非常了解，绝对是阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari），他是圣安德鲁斯大学的伊朗研究教授，也是《伊朗简史》（Very Short Introduction to Iran）的作者。阿里，非常感谢你来到这里。
on um i guess that you would agree i mean i know you agree because we've talked about it this idea that essentially everything comes from Persia. Yes, everything comes from Persia. You would be happy to go along with that. Well, I mean, you know, I think that the, you know, the Iranians or the Persians, I mean, we can discuss about the terms that we use. I mean, basically think that their contribution to human civilization has largely been underrated and largely ignored. And precisely, I think, as both of you have said, because the prism of looking at Iran has been really via the Islamic Revolution of 1979, it's very much colored our understanding and it sort of permeates everything we think about Iran,
嗯，我想你会同意的，我知道你同意，因为我们讨论过这个观点，即本质上一切都源于波斯。是的，一切都源于波斯。你会乐意接受这个说法吗？嗯，我的意思是，你知道，我认为伊朗人或波斯人——我们可以讨论我们使用的术语——基本上认为他们对人类文明的贡献在很大程度上被低估和忽视了。正如你们两位所说，这正是因为观察伊朗的棱镜实际上是通过1979年的伊斯兰革命，这极大地影响了我们的理解，并渗透到我们对伊朗的所有看法中，
whereas in actual fact, of course, Iran or the Persians have so much more to offer, I would say. Can I ask you a question? Sure. I talked about Iran. Tom talked about Persia. That's right. Are they the same or are they two different things that happen to have been in the same geographical location or is there a continuity? No, there is a continuity.
而事实上，当然，我认为伊朗或波斯人能提供的远不止这些。我可以问你一个问题吗？当然。我谈到了伊朗，汤姆谈到了波斯。没错。它们是同一个东西，还是恰好位于同一地理位置的两个不同事物？或者它们之间存在某种连续性？不，存在着连续性。
And I think, you know, hopefully my great achievement, if I have one as an academic of Iran, is to finally convince people that actually Iran and Persia are indeed the same thing, certainly in the Western record. So when we're looking at Iran, Iran is the name actually given to the country and the territory, the political territory, or even the culture, if you will, by the indigenous peoples. Persia is really, as Tom will know, is a sort of Greek-Roman sort of rendition and the reflection of a particular people or tribe of Iran. So if you look at a hierarchy, I mean, there's rather a good quote ascribed or attributed to Darius the Great, who basically says that I am an Archimened by family, a Persian by tribe, and an Iranian in terms of my peoples. So there's a sort of a tripartite division, which works quite well. I mean, obviously, you know, what he means by those
我认为，你知道，希望我作为一名伊朗学者如果有什么伟大的成就的话，那就是最终让人们相信伊朗和波斯确实是同一回事，至少在西方记录中是这样。所以当我们看伊朗时，“伊朗”实际上是原住民赋予这个国家、领土、政治领土甚至文化的名字。“波斯”正如汤姆所知，是希腊-罗马对伊朗特定民族或部落的一种称呼和反映。所以如果你看一个等级体系，大流士大帝有一句很好的名言，他基本上说：我是阿契美尼德家族的，波斯部落的，伊朗人民的。所以这是一种三分法，效果很好。我的意思是，显然，你知道，他所指的那些
things back 2,000, 2,500 years ago is obviously vastly different to what we might understand today but nonetheless it offers us an insight on how those on how those relate and i think far too many people uh western historians in some ways uh confuse the fact they sort of think that persia is a different place to iran and that iran sort of basically was invented in the 20th century. And most Iranians would be horrified at this. And most travellers, actually, most Western travellers who went to Iran in the modern period, by the modern period, Dominic, I mean, you know,
两千、两千五百年前的事物，显然与我们今天所理解的截然不同，但尽管如此，它为我们提供了关于它们如何关联的洞察。我认为太多的西方历史学家在某种程度上混淆了事实，他们认为波斯是一个与伊朗不同的地方，而伊朗基本上是在20世纪才被发明的。大多数伊朗人对此会感到震惊。而且大多数旅行者，实际上，大多数在现代时期去过伊朗的西方旅行者，多米尼克，我的意思是，
from the 17th century onwards. Yeah, yeah. In the 20th century, you know, all recognise this. I mean, they all say in their text, you know, the people who we call the Persians call themselves Iranians. So I think that's very clear. And I think for the avoidance of doubt, before we go forward to our top 10 hits, in a sense, I should also make clear that the term Iranian has nothing to do with the 19th century, you know, European racial connotation of Aryans and this sort of thing. I mean, it's basically a linguistic distinction,
从17世纪开始。是的，是的。在20世纪，你知道，所有人都认识到了这一点。我的意思是，他们在文中都说，我们称之为波斯人的人自称为伊朗人。所以我认为这非常清楚。为了避免疑虑，在我们进入前十名榜单之前，我还应该明确一点，即“伊朗人”这个词与19世纪欧洲关于雅利安人等种族内涵毫无关系。我的意思是，这基本上是一个语言学上的区别，
a linguistic definition that comes out and is basically applied. I think, and Tom will probably correct me actually on this, but I think, you know, for many Iranians in a sort of historical basis, I mean, Iran simply meant as the Franks do, basically, you know, noble born, freeborn, this sort of thing. So it's nothing,'s it's it's really little more than that um well ali on the topic of of how exactly we define iran or persia um could i um quote something from that great scholar of iran ben affleck um tom you found your level ben and ben says uh persia is very different from the arab middle east in terms of architecture and language. Even though we think of them as one big Middle Eastern area, in truth, Persia is quite distinct. What a great geopolitical mind.
一个衍生出来的语言学定义，并被应用。我想，汤姆可能会纠正我，但我想，你知道，对于许多伊朗人来说，在历史基础上，伊朗的意思简单来说就像“法兰克人”一样，基本上是“出身高贵、自由出生”的意思。所以这没什么，真的没别的了。嗯，阿里，关于我们究竟如何定义伊朗或波斯的话题，我可以引用那位伟大的伊朗学者本·阿弗莱克（Ben Affleck）的话吗？汤姆，你找到了你的水平，本。本说：“波斯在建筑和语言方面与阿拉伯中东非常不同。尽管我们认为它们是一个大的中东地区，但事实上，波斯是非常独特的。”多么伟大的地缘政治头脑。
But let's just tease that out because, of course, Persia, Iran, whatever you want to call it, is this great upland plateau. That's right. You've got the Zagros Mountains and then you go down the Zagros Mountains, you're into the kind of the flatlands of Iraq, of Mesopotamia. Historically, what's the relationship been between Persia and the rest of the Near East? Well, I mean, historically, I mean, if you look at the Iranians or the Iranian peoples, as we describe as a sort of a, let's take them as a linguistic grouping. I mean, obviously, they have a distinct Iranian language affiliated to an Indo-European heritage, which means that actually the language, the Persian language, not to confuse matters, but the Persian language spoken by the Iranians is basically much closer
但让我们深入探讨一下，因为当然，波斯、伊朗，无论你怎么称呼它，都是这片伟大的高地。没错。你有扎格罗斯山脉，然后你走下扎格罗斯山脉，就进入了伊拉克、美索不达米亚的平原。从历史上看，波斯与近东其他地区的关系如何？嗯，我的意思是，从历史上看，如果你看伊朗人或伊朗民族，正如我们将其描述为一种语言群体。我的意思是，显然，他们拥有一种独特的伊朗语言，隶属于印欧语系，这意味着实际上波斯语——不是为了混淆视听——但伊朗人说的波斯语基本上要亲近得多，
to the European languages that we speak. And you see that in sort of mother, father, you know, brother, ma, dar, ped, dar, bar, ordar, this sort of thing. So it's actually quite interesting in terms of that linguistic distinction. And of course, the Iranians occupying and having three sort of major imperial empires prior to the rise of the Arab Muslim caliphates of the 7th century meant that they had a certain presence in the Middle East, I have to say, long before the Arabs. So just give out those three empires. Just give us a span of the ancient history. So basically, if you look at, to give us some sort of chronological parameters, we have the first Persian empire, which actually is the empire that most people in the West would be familiar with, which is the Archaemenid Persian empire, which is the one that covers
与我们说的欧洲语言相比。你可以在“母亲、父亲、兄弟”这些词中看到这一点，ma-dar, ped-dar, bar-ordar，诸如此类。所以从语言区别的角度来看，这实际上非常有趣。当然，伊朗人在阿拉伯穆斯林在7世纪崛起之前拥有三个主要的帝国，这意味着他们在阿拉伯人之前很久就在中东拥有了一定的存在感。那么就列出那三个帝国吧。给我们一个古代历史的时间跨度。所以基本上，如果你看，为了给我们一些时间上的参数，我们有第一个波斯帝国，这实际上是西方大多数人熟悉的帝国，即阿契美尼德波斯帝国，它涵盖了
everything from Greece over to the Indus and down to Egypt and so on and so forth. The ones that lose at marathon. Well, yeah, but we're not Thermopylae, if I may say so. Yes, that's Cyrus the Great, Darius, Xerxes. Yeah, Xerxes, all the people that we know from our biblical and classical experiences. And we'll talk a little bit more about them, I'm sure, afterwards. And, of course, the quote you gave from Herodotus. I mean, I should remind us, of course,
从希腊到印度河，再到埃及等等。那些在马拉松战役中失败的人。嗯，是的，但如果我没记错的话，不是温泉关。是的，那是居鲁士大帝、大流士、薛西斯。是的，薛西斯，所有我们从圣经和古典经历中认识的人。我相信之后我们还会谈论更多关于他们的内容。当然，你引用的希罗多德的那句话。我的意思是，我应该提醒我们，当然，
Herodotus is technically a Persian subject, isn't he, Tom? So, I mean, he's a bit of a renegade, but he's, you know, he's the father of modern history. Not modern, but the father of history. So that's the first empire that's the empire that lasts for about 200 years and is basically overthrown by alexander the great and we can you know also talk a little bit about alexander's legacy in the persian world not all positive you won't be surprised to know and then subsequent to a sort of a hellenic interlude you
希罗多德在技术上是波斯的臣民，不是吗，汤姆？所以，我的意思是，他有点叛逆，但他，你知道，他是现代历史之父。不是现代，而是历史之父。所以那是第一个帝国，那个持续了大约200年的帝国，基本上被亚历山大大帝推翻了，我们也可以（你知道）谈谈亚历山大在波斯世界留下的遗产，并非全是积极的，你不会感到惊讶，然后在一个希腊化时期之后，你
then get the rise of a new dynasty which in the western uh lingo we know as the Parthians. And the Parthians are actually the longest lasting of the dynasties, quite decentralized, again, occupying much of the Iranian plateau. And it's with the Parthians that you get the first contest with the Romans and the Roman Republic, and then the Roman Empire, obviously, subsequently. The Parthians last from about 250 BC to around 250 AD. And then they are subsequently succeeded by probably the most influential of the pre-Islamic Persian empires, certainly as far as Iran is concerned, and that is the Sasanians. And the Sasanian dynasty claims a much longer
然后迎来了新王朝的崛起，在西方术语中我们称之为帕提亚人。帕提亚人实际上是持续时间最长的王朝，相当分散，同样占据了大部分伊朗高原。正是与帕提亚人，你有了与罗马和罗马共和国，然后是罗马帝国的第一次较量。帕提亚人从公元前250年左右持续到公元250年左右。随后，他们被可能是前伊斯兰波斯帝国中最具影响力的王朝所取代，至少就伊朗而言，那就是萨珊王朝。萨珊王朝声称拥有更长的
heritage on the plateau, and lasts really then until the mid-7th century, until the overthrow by the Arab Muslim armies. But it's the Sasanians that really set the scene far more than the previous dynasties in actual fact. They're the ones that compile a sort of historical record. They're the ones that actually give the name Iran to that political territory. And if I was to say my first, first, if I can put it that way, is that, you know, there is a suggestion, which I'm sort of happy to accept, really, not entirely uncritically, but certainly accept, is that, you know, Iran is one of the, if not the first, territorially defined political unit that has a degree of continuity to it from the period of antiquity
高原遗产，实际上一直持续到7世纪中叶，直到被阿拉伯穆斯林军队推翻。但正是萨珊王朝，实际上比之前的王朝更奠定了局面。他们是编写历史记录的人。他们是真正将“伊朗”这个名字赋予该政治领土的人。如果我要说我的第一点，如果我可以这样说的话，那就是，你知道，有一个建议，我很高兴接受，真的，不是完全不加批判地，但肯定接受，那就是，你知道，伊朗是，如果不是第一个，也是第一个具有领土定义的政治单位，从古代时期到
to the present. So the Iran that is set up by the Sasanians, the empire of Iran, is basically, you know, the sort of cultural territory, if not entirely the political territory, because it was bigger, it is bigger, obviously, than what we have today, that we find in modern Iran. So Iran is the first country? Well, I mean, that would be the claim. I mean, obviously, when we get into it, you know, Iran, as far as the Iranians are concerned in historical places, is the first kingdom. I mean, it's the first dominion of man over nature. So but that's largely, you know, obviously part of the mythical heritage. But it's one that Iranian nationalists are very, very keen to promote. Some of the some of the some of the chronology goes really quite far back and wholly unrealistic.
现在都具有一定程度的连续性。所以萨珊王朝建立的伊朗，伊朗帝国，基本上是，你知道，那种文化领土，如果不是完全的政治领土，因为它比我们今天拥有的要大，显然要大，我们在现代伊朗发现的。所以伊朗是第一个国家？嗯，我的意思是，这会是这种说法。我的意思是，显然，当我们深入研究它时，你知道，就历史上的伊朗人而言，伊朗是第一个王国。我的意思是，它是人类对自然的第一个统治。所以但这在很大程度上，你知道，显然是神话遗产的一部分。但这是伊朗民族主义者非常、非常热衷于推广的。一些时间表真的追溯得非常远，完全不现实。
But I'm happy to sort of chat, though. You know, they say it's not just two and a half thousand years. I mean, let's get it back further. You can sit down with a number of Iranians, you know, and we can extend back. There was quite a famous account, actually, in the early 20th century when a nationalist historographer, which I always find quite entertaining, calculated the length of the kingdom of Iran, going back through the mythical great epic poem of Iran, the Book of Kings. And he calculated that the length of the kingdom could be traced back 10 billion years.
但我很高兴聊天。你知道，他们说这不仅仅是两千五百年。我的意思是，让我们追溯得更远。你可以和许多伊朗人坐下来，你知道，我们可以扩展回去。实际上，在20世纪初有一个非常著名的说法，当时一位民族主义史学家，我总是觉得这很有趣，计算了伊朗王国的长度，通过伊朗神话中的伟大史诗《列王纪》追溯回去。他计算出王国的长度可以追溯到100亿年前。
And obviously someone else pointed out this predated the creation of the world. So these sort of things. That puts the Romans in the world. You know, so these are things. That puts the Romans in their place. I know, that's right. So, I mean, if you accept that, then everything does begin in Iran, obviously. But Ali, obviously, what complicates the picture in terms of the continuity? Because clearly there is this incredible sense of continuity. The last Shah of Iran famously had great celebrations at Persepolis, the great Kaimanid capital.
显然有人指出这早于世界的创造。所以这些事情。这把罗马人放在了世界里。你知道，所以这些事情。这把罗马人放在了他们的位置上。我知道，没错。所以，我的意思是，如果你接受这一点，那么一切确实始于伊朗，显然。但阿里，显然，就连续性而言，什么使情况复杂化了？因为显然有一种令人难以置信的连续性感。伊朗的最后一位沙阿在波斯波利斯，那个伟大的阿契美尼德首都，举行了盛大的庆祝活动。
And he jetted over cooks from Paris and a great extravaganza. And then, of course, we know what happened to him. And I suppose what complicates this picture of continuity is that the Sasanian Empire in the 7th century collapses before the Arabs. That's right. And they introduce Islam. And to what extent is Islam a radical rupture? And to what extent does Iranian culture come to an accommodation with Islam? And there is a genuine sense of continuity.
他从巴黎空运了厨师，举办了一场盛大的狂欢。然后，当然，我们知道他发生了什么。我想，使这种连续性图景复杂化的是，7世纪的萨珊帝国在阿拉伯人面前崩溃了。没错。他们引入了伊斯兰教。伊斯兰教在多大程度上是一种激进的断裂？伊朗文化在多大程度上与伊斯兰教达成了妥协？并且存在一种真正的连续性感。
Well, I mean, my favorite phrase in all this and always to disarm my Arab colleagues is to say, you know, captive Persia took prisoner her conquerors. I've never actually known who actually said that first, but I'd like to sort of lay claim to it. But it's essentially this notion that there have been a series of ruptures in Iranian history, clearly from Alexander the Great all the way through, and you get the Arabs are obviously in the Muslim conquest is a very serious, almost, you know, psychological, ideological rupture, obviously, and bringing a new religion, a new calendar, so on and so forth. But then also, you have the Mongol invasions of the 13th century that are particularly devastating on a socio-economic level. But in all three cases, I mean, you find this sort of cultural confidence of the Persians, and I Arabs, what you find is that the Iranians basically take Islam
嗯，我的意思是，我在所有这些中，为了解除我阿拉伯同事的武装，最喜欢的一句话是说，你知道，“被俘的波斯俘虏了她的征服者”。我从来不知道是谁先说的，但我很想认领它。但这本质上是这样一种观念，即伊朗历史上发生了一系列断裂，显然从亚历山大大帝一直到现在，阿拉伯人显然在穆斯林征服中是一个非常严重的，几乎是，你知道，心理上的、意识形态上的断裂，显然，带来了新的宗教、新的历法等等。但随后，你还有13世纪的蒙古入侵，这在社会经济层面上是特别具有破坏性的。但在所有这三种情况下，我的意思是，你发现了波斯人那种文化自信，而阿拉伯人，你发现的是伊朗人基本上接受了伊斯兰教，
and turn it from what is essentially an Arab religion into a global universal religion in which, you know, non-Arabs are equally valid. And therefore, Persians... So, Ali, what you're saying is Islam is actually Persian. Well, there are some... I think that would be pushing it a bit, to be perfectly honest. There are a number of people in Iran who would certainly claim that the Islam that you see today in terms of a global universalist religion is really something which has been de-Arabized. Impersionized. I mean, to some extent. I mean, why quibble? But that's certainly one of the views. I mean, I wouldn't necessarily, I have to say, subscribe to that. But however, it's obviously a religion adhered by all. And that's the argument. Of course, you see that with Shiaism as well and
并将其从本质上的一种阿拉伯宗教转变为一种全球性的普遍宗教，其中，你知道，非阿拉伯人同样有效。因此，波斯人……所以，阿里，你的意思是伊斯兰教实际上是波斯的？嗯，有一些……我认为这有点过分了，说实话。伊朗有许多人肯定会声称，你今天看到的作为一种全球普遍主义宗教的伊斯兰教，实际上是已经被“去阿拉伯化”的东西。波斯化了。我的意思是，在某种程度上。我的意思是，为什么要吹毛求疵？但这当然是观点之一。我的意思是，我未必，我必须说，认同这一点。但是，无论如何，这显然是所有人坚持的宗教。这就是论点。当然，你也可以在什叶派中看到这一点，以及
other things. But you see it also with the Mongols. Iran is the only part of the Mongol Empire that basically absorbed the Mongols within Persian culture. In China, they expelled the Mongols, you see, but the Iranians somehow just absorbed them. And you still see lots of traces of the Mongol and Turkic conquest in Iran. Ali, you've given us this huge list of things that you think that Persia basically invented, for which we should be getting down on our knees and groveling before the Persians. I wouldn't go that far. We're very magnanimous.
其他事情。但你也可以在蒙古人身上看到这一点。伊朗是蒙古帝国中唯一基本上将蒙古人吸收进波斯文化的部分。在中国，他们驱逐了蒙古人，你看，但伊朗人不知何故只是吸收了他们。你仍然可以在伊朗看到许多蒙古和突厥征服的痕迹。阿里，你给了我们一份巨大的清单，列出了你认为波斯基本上发明的东西，我们应该跪下来在波斯人面前匍匐。我不会走那么远。我们非常宽宏大量。
Frustrating ourselves before the Great Queen. Frustrating ourselves, yes, of course. I wouldn't want you to, I wouldn't want you, I just think that, you know, there are a number of, I mean, the one thing which I think you should acknowledge is that basically, you know, Persia is the midwife to the West, isn't it? I mean, there would be no West without the Persians. Okay. So, Ali, on that theme, you've prepared a list of, what, of top ten things that the Persians have given the world? I mean, I have to say I felt very restricted by ten, but let's keep going.
在伟大的女王面前挫败自己。挫败自己，是的，当然。我不想让你，我不想让你，我只是认为，你知道，有许多，我的意思是，我认为你应该承认的一件事是，基本上，你知道，波斯是西方的助产士，不是吗？我的意思是，没有波斯人就没有西方。好的。所以，阿里，在这个主题上，你准备了一份，什么，波斯人给世界的十大贡献清单？我的意思是，我必须说我感到被十个限制住了，但让我们继续。
There look to me to be more than ten on this list, Tom. Yeah, because there's certain subsets, aren't there, really? Basically, Ali has come prepared for ten podcasts. Okay. Well, how long have we got? We've got, what, five minutes left? Ten minutes, I guess, for this half? We're going to rattle these off. Right. So let's kick off. okay well we how long we got we got what five minutes left ten minutes i guess rattle these off right so so let's kick off what's what's your first selection well i mean i i think
在这个清单上对我来说似乎不止十个，汤姆。是的，因为有某些子集，不是吗，真的？基本上，阿里已经为十个播客做好了准备。好的。那么我们还有多少时间？我们还有，什么，五分钟？十分钟，我想，这一半？我们要快速讲完这些。对。所以让我们开始吧。好的，我们还有多少时间？我们还有，什么，五分钟？十分钟，我想，快速讲完这些。对。所以让我们开始吧。你的第一个选择是什么？嗯，我的意思是，我，我想
we can i think we can start with that sort of issue of of persia being the first kingdom and and uh basically the the as as and i will i will i will elicit here the support of that great, great German philosopher Hegel to remind us that history begins with the Persians. So our understanding of history as a progressive movement, in a sense, of enlightenment, if you will, really begins with the Persians. Now, like all good historiography, we don't like to quote the next clause that Hegel puts out, that it starts with the Persians. Now, like all good historiography, we don't like to quote the next clause that Hegel puts out that, you know, it starts with the Persians and then left them. I wouldn't want to, you know, use his next phrase. Let's stick with the first part. But I think,
我们可以，我想我们可以从波斯作为第一个王国的问题开始，并且，呃，基本上，正如，我将在这里引出那位伟大的、伟大的德国哲学家黑格尔的支持，提醒我们历史始于波斯。所以我们对历史作为一种进步运动的理解，在某种意义上，启蒙运动，如果你愿意的话，确实始于波斯。现在，像所有好的史学一样，我们不喜欢引用黑格尔提出的下一句，即它始于波斯。现在，像所有好的史学一样，我们不喜欢引用黑格尔提出的下一句，即“它始于波斯，然后离开了他们”。我不想，你知道，使用他的下一句话。让我们坚持第一部分。但我认为，
you know, this idea of Iran as the first kingdom, the first dominion of man over nature, the first place where history begins effectively. And, you know, as I was saying to Dominic earlier, this territorially delimited state, which is also the midwife, in a sense, in an ancient sense, to that concept of the West. So it's interesting, as you both said, you know, we don't have this notion of Persia as a great civilization in the same way as we have with the Romans and the Greeks and even the Babylonians or Egyptians to be honest but uh nonetheless we are there as best supporting actor and I would like to move us from best supporting actor really to center stage I think we should be getting the best actor award frankly Ali did that all kick off with um Cyrus the Great was he the person who
你知道，这种将伊朗视为第一个王国、人类对自然的第一个统治、历史实际上开始的第一个地方的观念。而且，正如我早些时候对多米尼克所说，这种领土界定的国家，在某种意义上，在古代意义上，也是西方概念的助产士。所以这很有趣，正如你们两位所说，你知道，我们没有这种将波斯视为伟大文明的观念，就像我们对待罗马人和希腊人，甚至老实说巴比伦人或埃及人那样，但呃，尽管如此，我们作为最佳男配角在那里，我想让我们从最佳男配角真正转到舞台中央。我认为我们应该获得最佳男主角奖，坦率地说。阿里，这一切是从居鲁士大帝开始的吗？他是那个
basically created Persia uh yes depending who you talk to I mean i yes i mean i think in in in the popular understanding the father of the nation as uh as was noted is basically uh is cyrus the great who who basically binds the medes and the persians together into the first of these iranian empires and the the the uh this persian empire from you know 559 bc to when would it be, Tom? 333 BC, something like that. That's the first of the Persian empires, which basically establishes, and I, you know, I would add to that, the first universal empire. Yeah. So I completely agree about the idea that the Persians are the first people who formulate their imperial rule as something universal. That's right.
基本上创造了波斯的人吗？是的，取决于你和谁谈。我的意思是，我，是的，我的意思是，我认为在流行的理解中，正如所指出的，国家的父亲基本上是居鲁士大帝，他基本上将米底人和波斯人结合在一起，形成了这些伊朗帝国中的第一个，而且这个波斯帝国从（你知道）公元前559年到什么时候，汤姆？公元前333年，差不多吧。那是第一个波斯帝国，它基本上建立了，而且我，你知道，我会补充一点，第一个普遍帝国。是的。所以我完全同意波斯人是第一个将他们的帝国统治制定为某种普遍事物的民族的观点。没错。
And indeed moral, that it reflects kind of the patterning of the universe. Absolutely. Absolutely. universal that's right and indeed moral that it reflects the kind of patterning of the universe but just slightly to play devil's advocate so sires the great he his fame is is immense and he's famous because he is hugely praised by two people who he conquers one of them the greeks and the greeks think he's the model of of a great man that's right and the other course the jews and the jews and the by he's he's the mess. He's the anointed one praised as such by Isaiah. But all we really have from the Persians is kind of tomb inscriptions. So in what sense are the Persians inventing history when they're not actually writing it down in the way that the Greeks and the Jews are? Well, that's a very, yeah, that's a very interesting point you've made there, Tom. I think that the main thing is that we have to understand
而且确实是道德上的，它反映了宇宙的某种模式。绝对的。绝对的。普遍的，没错，而且确实是道德上的，它反映了宇宙的某种模式。但只是稍微扮演一下魔鬼代言人，所以居鲁士大帝，他的名声是巨大的，他之所以出名是因为他受到了他征服的两个人的极大赞扬，其中一个是希腊人，希腊人认为他是伟大人物的典范，没错，另一个当然是犹太人，犹太人，他，他是弥赛亚。他是受膏者，被以赛亚如此赞美。但我们从波斯人那里真正得到的只是某种墓碑铭文。那么，当他们没有像希腊人和犹太人那样真正写下来时，波斯人在什么意义上发明了历史？嗯，这是一个非常，是的，这是一个非常有趣的点，你提到了，汤姆。我认为主要的事情是我们必须理解
is that one of the contributions to history that I think the Persians make is if you understand the way in which history is written. I mean, one of the things that, you know, are sort of mythological narratives and what we might call historical narratives. The Iranians, certainly after the Hellenic period and into the Parthians and the Sasanian period, tend to sort of write a history that is largely mythologically based. I mean, they derive a mythological narrative of their descent. Now, the interesting thing with that is that certainly the Archimedes tend to sort of get erased from that history in a very detailed sense. But they do exist
是，我认为波斯人对历史的贡献之一是，如果你理解历史被书写的方式。我的意思是，你知道，我们所谓的某种神话叙事和我们可能称之为历史叙事的事情之一。伊朗人，当然在希腊化时期之后，进入帕提亚和萨珊时期，倾向于书写一种在很大程度上基于神话的历史。我的意思是，他们推导出了他们血统的神话叙事。现在，有趣的是，当然阿契美尼德王朝倾向于在那种历史中以一种非常详细的方式被抹去。但他们确实存在
in the mythological narratives. They are there. And the figure of Kurosh, which is the Persian for Cyrus, does appear in a number of these mythological narratives. He is, however, somewhat demoted in that narrative under the sort of the world kings that exist. So there is a historical narrative. It's just not a historical narrative that we would recognise, but it's a very profound historical narrative that is more mythological in a sense in its construction and full of folklore than the history, you know,
在神话叙事中。他们就在那里。而库鲁什（Kurosh）这个人物，也就是居鲁士的波斯语，确实出现在许多这些神话叙事中。然而，他在那种叙事中被降级了，在现存的某种世界之王之下。所以有一个历史叙事。它只是不是我们所能识别的历史叙事，但它是一个非常深刻的历史叙事，在某种意义上，它的构建更具神话色彩，充满了民间传说，而不是历史，你知道，
the history we would have in terms of the discipline that we would understand it and of of the discipline that we would understand it and you we collectively would understand it but i think it's just a different type of history if i can put it that way i'm trying hard but uh hopefully you will ali take us through some of the things on your list um uh the things that you think the persians well i mean i i think there are a number of things that i've sort of tried to divide so if we look at um uh i've sort of dealt with the i suppose the political side, I think there are a number of things that I've sort of tried to divide. So if we look at, I've sort of dealt with the, I suppose, the political side of it. But there are other things that I think are quite important.
我们所理解的学科意义上的历史，以及我们集体所理解的，但我认为这只是不同类型的历史，如果我可以这样说的话。我正在努力，但呃，希望你会，阿里，带我们看看你清单上的一些事情，嗯，呃，你认为波斯人……嗯，我的意思是，我认为有许多事情，我试图划分，所以如果我们看，嗯，呃，我试图划分一些事情。所以如果我们看，我处理了，我想是政治方面。但还有其他我认为相当重要的事情。
Some of the contributions to religion. I mean, we mentioned about the Persian contributions to Islam, obviously. But I think the Persian contributions to religion and religious thought have been pretty impressive. Certainly through Zoroastrianism. And Zoroastrianism was the pre-Islamic religion of Persia or Iran. And Zoroastrianism provided a number of ideas. I know I'm going to get some pushback from Tom, but let's try it. No, you're not. I completely agree. I completely agree. You know, in terms of, I mean, some fairly sort of simple things, well, things that we take for
一些对宗教的贡献。我的意思是，我们提到了波斯对伊斯兰教的贡献，显然。但我认为波斯对宗教和宗教思想的贡献相当令人印象深刻。当然是通过琐罗亚斯德教。琐罗亚斯德教是波斯或伊朗的前伊斯兰宗教。琐罗亚斯德教提供了一些想法。我知道我会从汤姆那里得到一些反击，但让我们试试。不，你不会。我完全同意。我完全同意。你知道，就，我的意思是，一些相当简单的东西，嗯，我们今天视为
granted today, of course, which just shows how effective it's been. This notion of the end of times, for instance, and a spiritual rede redeemer these are quite Zoroastrian you know and then they're sort of bound in with that sort of Judaic heritage that sort of uh then uh come come through in Christianity yeah because we should say that the the the people of Judah of Jerusalem get taken by the Babylonians to Babylon by the rivers of Babylon weeping so the Jews are in the Jews are in captivity in Babylon and then basically released. And then Cyrus lets them come back.
理所当然的东西，当然，这只是显示了它有多么有效。例如，这种末世论的观念，以及一位精神救赎者，这些都相当琐罗亚斯德教，你知道，然后它们与那种犹太遗产结合在一起，那种，呃，然后，呃，通过基督教传下来。是的，因为我们应该说，犹大耶路撒冷的人民被巴比伦人带到了巴比伦，在巴比伦河畔哭泣，所以犹太人在巴比伦被俘，然后基本上被释放了。然后居鲁士让他们回来了。
Yes, yes. Which is why the Jews love the Persians. Do they come back with Persian ideas then? Is that basically the argument? Yes, yes, that's the idea. That's the idea. So Judaism is Persian? No, no, I mean, let's not exaggerate
是的，是的。这就是为什么犹太人热爱波斯人。他们带着波斯的想法回来了吗？这基本上是论点吗？是的，是的，这就是想法。这就是想法。所以犹太教是波斯的？不，不，我的意思是，不要夸大
to diminish the effectiveness of this argument. I mean, because you were... I'm a stranger to that tactic. No, don't do that. No, because I mean, I think the interesting thing is, if you look at two biblical texts, I think it's the book of Daniel and the book of Revelation. They carry some fairly strong sort of Zoroastrian tropes and ideas in there. I mean,
以削弱这个论点的有效性。我的意思是，因为你当时……我对那种策略很陌生。不，不要那样做。不，因为我的意思是，我认为有趣的是，如果你看两部圣经文本，我认为是《但以理书》和《启示录》。它们携带了一些相当强烈的琐罗亚斯德教的隐喻和思想。我的意思是，
obviously, these are things that scholars far brighter than me will be dissecting and interrogating looking at these texts. But if you look at the, once the Jews returned from the Babylonian captivity, and of course, the main point is, is a lot of them didn't, a lot of them stayed in Mesopotamia, which is the heartland of the sort of Persian Empire, and imbued a lot of these ideas and sort of produced them. But you can see Zoroastrian ideas coming through. And there's even parts of the text where they sort of say there are words that are being used that are clearly Persian. But the whole notion, for instance, of there's a great concept in Zoroastrian eschatology of a sort of a dragon king. To the end of days.
显然，这些是比我聪明得多的学者将剖析和审问，审视这些文本的事情。但如果你看，一旦犹太人从巴比伦之囚中返回，当然，主要的一点是，他们中的许多人没有回来，他们中的许多人留在了美索不达米亚，这是波斯帝国的中心地带，并灌输了许多这些想法并产生它们。但你可以看到琐罗亚斯德教的思想传过来。甚至在文本中有部分，他们说有使用的词显然是波斯的。但整个观念，例如，在琐罗亚斯德教末世论中有一个伟大的概念，即某种龙王。到末日。
Yes, in the end of days. And although the end of days has a certain circularity to it, but nonetheless, yes, sort of end of days, a sort of great dragon king that is then overthrown and whatever, and then you have peace and justice, as one might hope. And the dragon king, in the way it's described in Zoroastrian texts, has strong similarities, I should say, with the beast in the Book of Revelation. So it's quite interesting.
是的，在末日。虽然末日有一种循环性，但尽管如此，是的，某种末日，某种伟大的龙王，然后被推翻等等，然后你拥有和平与正义，正如人们所希望的那样。而在琐罗亚斯德教文本中描述的龙王，我应该说，与《启示录》中的兽有很强的相似之处。所以这很有趣。
Now, again, none of these are definitive, but in what would be an ancient history, really, or any history for that matter. But nonetheless, I think it does make for quite a strong case that there's a huge... I mean, one of the things that I think the Persians have been extremely good at exporting, if I may say so, is religion and religious ideas. And the whole idea of the world being divided, I mean, Herodotus was saying that the Persians get taught truth and that, of course, the counterpoint to that is the lie.
现在，同样，这些都不是决定性的，但在古代历史中，或者就此而言的任何历史中。但尽管如此，我认为这确实构成了一个相当强有力的案例，即有一个巨大的……我的意思是，我认为波斯人非常擅长出口的一件事，如果我可以这样说的话，是宗教和宗教思想。而且整个世界被划分的观念，我的意思是，希罗多德说波斯人被教导真理，而当然，与之相对的是谎言。
The lie, yes, absolutely. And the sense of the world divided into good and evil and light and darkness is obviously hugely strong. So I think we could chalk up that the persians have invented empire history um judaism christianity and islam so that's not bad so i think we should probably i'm not i'm not gonna go i'm not gonna get into judaism christianity islam okay they made significant contribution okay it's too late it's too late it's done yeah i hear you i hear you so hear you. So let's leave it at that and we'll take a break. And when we come back, you'll have some more, I think possibly including gardening.
谎言，是的，绝对。而且世界被划分为善与恶、光明与黑暗的感觉显然非常强烈。所以我认为我们可以把波斯人发明了帝国、历史、嗯，犹太教、基督教和伊斯兰教记在账上，所以这还不错，所以我认为我们可能应该，我不会，我不会进入犹太教、基督教、伊斯兰教，好的，他们做出了重大贡献，好的，太晚了，太晚了，完成了，是的，我听到了，我听到了，所以听到了。所以让我们到此为止，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，你会有更多，我想可能包括园艺。
So let's see you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
那么到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. With me is dominic of course and ali ansari who is talking us through basically why the persians have invented everything um ali is is giving us his list top 10 things that the persians have given the world um we've already had empire and we've had religion um so ali what what's next on your list of top 10? Well, the other thing I think is very important is that, you know, the Persians invented paradise. But I suppose it needs a bit of qualification here. Really, the idea of a walled garden, a walled garden that's a planned, you know, and structured garden. This is something that's very closely associated, actually, with the figure of Cyrus the Great, who archaeologists have discovered had a rather spectacular sort of walled garden at his capital in Pasadagai in southern Iran.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。和我在一起的当然是多米尼克，还有阿里·安萨里，他正在向我们讲述波斯人基本上发明了一切的原因。嗯，阿里正在给我们他的波斯给世界的十大贡献清单。我们已经有了帝国，我们有了宗教，所以阿里，你的十大清单上的下一个是什么？嗯，我认为非常重要的另一件事是，你知道，波斯人发明了天堂（Paradise）。但我认为这里需要一点限定。真的，围墙花园的观念，一个规划好的、结构化的花园。这与居鲁士大帝的人物非常密切相关，考古学家发现他在伊朗南部的首都帕萨尔加德有一个相当壮观的围墙花园。
And, of course, this Persian affection, shall we say, for the natural world. I'm going to make a claim here, actually, that they're really the original environmentalists, by the way. So you can see where I'm going. You know, the Green Party really did start in Iran. But this sort of affection for the natural world, gardens, the sort of the order and beauty of the natural world, I think is something that's very closely associated with the Persians throughout history, actually. and beauty of the natural world, I think is something that's very closely associated with
当然，这种波斯人对自然世界的喜爱，我们可以这样说。我在这里要提出一个主张，顺便说一句，他们实际上是最初的环保主义者。所以你可以看到我要去哪里。你知道，绿党确实始于伊朗。但这种对自然世界、花园、自然世界的秩序和美的喜爱，我认为是整个历史上与波斯人非常密切相关的事情，实际上。
the Persians throughout history, actually. And one that, you know, you even find, you know, European commentators and others, you know, commenting on it. There's a lovely, lovely narrative that I've read, which actually, I believe comes from one of the, I think it comes from Xenophon, actually, but Tom, again, you can uh where um a spartan king goes to visit saris the younger in his in his uh in his uh satrapal his governor's palace in in sardis and um comments very uh generously about the splendid nature of his garden and says you know you must congratulate your slaves for having you know done so much work much work. And of course, Cyrus the Younger laughs and rather, he says, no, no, you know, I've done this by my own hand.
波斯人整个历史上，实际上。而且，你知道，你甚至发现，你知道，欧洲评论家和其他人，你知道，对此发表评论。我读过一个可爱、可爱的叙事，实际上，我相信它来自其中一个，我想它实际上来自色诺芬，但汤姆，同样，你可以，呃，在那里，一位斯巴达国王去拜访小居鲁士，在他的，在他的，呃，总督府，在萨迪斯，并且，呃，非常慷慨地评论了他花园的壮丽性质，并说，你知道，你必须祝贺你的奴隶，因为他们，你知道，做了这么多工作。当然，小居鲁士笑了，而是，他说，不，不，你知道，我这是亲手做的。
And the Spartan king is rather shocked at this, that he should sully his own hands by getting in the dirt and all this. But Cyrus says that, this is Cyrus the Younger, I should stress. Cyrus the Younger says, you know, I always feel it very important that until one has labored with one's own hands, one should not sit down for a meal, you know, and that sort of thing. I mean, it's this sort of idea that let's get out there and let's have a bit of, you know.
而斯巴达国王对此感到相当震惊，他竟然通过弄脏手来玷污自己的双手，所有这些。但居鲁士说，这是小居鲁士，我应该强调。小居鲁士说，你知道，我总是觉得非常重要，直到一个人亲手劳动，一个人就不应该坐下来吃饭，你知道，诸如此类。我的意思是，这是一种观念，让我们出去，让我们有一点，你知道。
I think it's one of the, yeah, one of the most wonderful things about the Persian Empire is the way the kings are portrayed as great gardeners. Yes. That's the role they play. And I think it meant that one of the ways in which Xerxes is encouraged to invade Greece is they say, well, you know, there's some amazing trees and plants there that you won't have. You know, it's kind of like going to a garden centre or something. Yeah. I mean, I'd like to go and
我认为波斯帝国最美妙的事情之一，就是国王们被描绘成伟大的园丁。是的，这就是他们扮演的角色。我认为这意味着，薛西斯之所以被鼓励入侵希腊，是因为人们告诉他，那里有一些你所没有的奇妙树木和植物。你知道，这就像去园艺中心之类的。是的，我的意思是，我想去
collect some more trees for my garden back in Persepolis. Ali, can I jump in as somebody who's never been to Iran? So I think probably a lot of our listeners won't have been to Iran either. So my perception, which may be completely and utterly false, is that Iran, Tom talked about as a plateau, is that it's quite a sort of dusty and hot place. So is the paradise, the kind of walled garden, is that a refuge from the heat? Does it have to be created? Or am I completely wrong? And is Persia actually much greener and more verdant? Well, I mean, it's a good question. Because of course, in the ancient period, the argument is, is that southern Iran was much more verdant than we have today. But it's certainly true. I think your central point is quite true that it was because of the sparseness of the landscape in
为我在波斯波利斯的花园收集更多树木。阿里，我可以插一句吗？作为一个从未去过伊朗的人，我想我们很多听众可能也没去过伊朗。所以我的印象——可能完全是错误的——是伊朗，正如汤姆所说的，是一个高原，是一个相当尘土飞扬且炎热的地方。那么，天堂，那种围墙花园，是躲避酷暑的避难所吗？它是必须人工创造出来的吗？还是我完全错了？波斯实际上是否更加绿意盎然？嗯，这是一个好问题。因为当然，在古代，人们认为伊朗南部比我们今天看到的要绿得多。但确实，我认为你的核心观点很正确，正是因为景观在某些方面比较稀疏，
some ways that the Iranians developed vast irrigation networks and plans for, you know, water supply. I mean, they were quite skilled at that, and therefore developed, I suppose, these walled gardens as a refuge. Now, that's not to say that the plateau itself i mean let's not forget because there is this sort of you know how should we say rather orientalist view of the middle east as all being deserts and camels um there are deserts in iran obviously but there are also jungles in iran i mean if you go up to the caspian and the northern areas it's very verdant so it's uh you know there's a whole range of different sort of climate types. But certainly in the south, and I think this sort of idea,
伊朗人才开发了庞大的灌溉网络和供水计划。我的意思是，他们在这方面非常熟练，因此，我想，他们开发了这些围墙花园作为避难所。现在，这并不是说高原本身——我的意思是，别忘了，因为有一种关于中东的、怎么说呢，相当东方主义的观点，认为那里全是沙漠和骆驼——伊朗显然有沙漠，但也有丛林。我的意思是，如果你去里海和北部地区，那里非常葱郁，所以，你知道，那里有各种各样的气候类型。但肯定是在南部，而且我认为这种想法，
the affection for a garden was precisely, as you say it, that, you know, it's a way of harnessing nature to provide a refuge, really, in an otherwise rather sort of bleak landscape in some ways. And those gardens, I mean, I remember going to esfahan and going to a garden there and and it was kind of quite hot you went into the garden and it was cool there were fountains and the synthesis of the the the vegetation with the architecture was so breathtakingly beautiful and again and again i kept going around ir thinking, you know, these places are as beautiful as any I've ever seen. And you can see why the idea of that these walled gardens are the kind of places where God would have walked and talked to man.
对花园的喜爱正如你所说，这是一种利用自然来提供避难所的方式，在某种程度上，那里的景观在其他方面相当荒凉。那些花园，我的意思是，我记得去伊斯法罕，去过那里的一个花园，当时天气相当热，你走进花园，里面很凉爽，有喷泉，植被与建筑的融合是如此令人叹为观止的美丽。我一次又一次地在伊朗四处走动，心想，这些地方和我见过的任何地方一样美丽。你可以明白为什么会有这种想法：这些围墙花园是上帝行走并与人交谈的地方。
You can entirely see where it would have come from. But you can see also this sort of notion of the Garden of Eden, you see, of course. I mean, it's this idea of a walled garden and a and as a paradise on earth a reflection of that and and you're quite right you know the way it's been designed is to you know bring a measure of uh comfort coolness with the water the water sort of features a very very deliberate um uh you know in a way to to to to give you that sense of a sort of a little refuge away from the uh the troubles of the world so ali should we should we well as paradise, should we clock up gardening? Yes, I think so.
你完全可以理解这种想法的由来。但你也可以看到这种伊甸园的概念，当然。我的意思是，这是一种围墙花园的想法，作为人间的天堂，是它的反映。你说得很对，你知道，它的设计方式是为了带来一定程度的舒适和凉爽，水景是非常非常刻意的，在某种程度上，是为了让你感受到一种远离世界烦恼的小小避难所。所以阿里，我们应该把园艺算作天堂的一部分吗？是的，我想是的。
I think, and really the origins of environmental thinking, I think, would be good. Yeah, Dominic, you happy with that? Yeah, I'm very happy with that. I buy that. Yeah, okay. I like it. Okay, we'll bung them in.
我认为，环境思维的起源，我觉得会很好。是的，多米尼克，你对此满意吗？是的，我非常满意。我接受这个。是的，好的。我喜欢它。好的，我们把它们加进去。
I think that's important. And it's the word paradise from a Persian word or a Greek word. It is, yes. It's a Persian word. Right, and the Greeks then took it. Did they? And then, is that right. Right, and the Greeks then took it. Is that right, Tom, that the Greeks took it and that's how we get it? Okay, interesting.
我认为这很重要。那么“天堂”（paradise）这个词是来自波斯语还是希腊语？是的，它是。它是一个波斯语词汇。对，然后希腊人采用了它。是吗？然后，是这样吗？对，然后希腊人采用了它。是这样吗，汤姆，希腊人采用了它，这就是我们得到这个词的方式？好的，有趣。
Go on, Ali, give us some more. So I thought we might move to a little bit of leisure and sport now because that would be quite interesting. Now, I would like to think that the Persians invented cricket, but I have alas no evidence uh of this um and there are sort of uh arguments about polo of course i mean polo is a very prominent you know because of the sort of the the the training it gives but the one right that riding horses isn't it yeah well let's just say horses horses are a big deal for the persians yes yes that's right i
继续，阿里，再给我们讲讲。所以我想我们现在可以转到休闲和运动方面，因为那会很有趣。现在，我愿意认为波斯人发明了板球，但我遗憾地没有任何证据，而且关于马球当然有一些争论，我的意思是马球非常突出，因为它是那种训练带来的，但有一点是对的，骑马，不是吗？是的，好吧，我们只能说马，马对波斯人来说是一件大事。是的，是的，没错，我
mean the horses are a big deal but i i wouldn't want you know there are areas where even i won't tread you know which is the idea that did the did the persians uh invent the stirrup for instance i mean it's a very very controversial debate and uh yes i mean i know tom would be quite shocked by this uh so would the franks and also all the you know the uh the carolingians however um there is a suggestion there has been, but I, I don't want to go there because as, as Tom's reaction indicates, it would get me into a lot of trouble. However, um,
意思是马是一件大事，但我不想，你知道，有些领域即使是我也不会涉足，那就是波斯人是否发明了马镫，这是一个非常有争议的辩论。是的，我知道汤姆会对此感到非常震惊，法兰克人也会，还有所有的加洛林王朝。然而，有一种说法，确实有，但我不想深入探讨，因为正如汤姆的反应所表明的那样，这会给我带来很多麻烦。然而，
I'm open to all kinds of farfetched series. You keep, you keep them firing. You see one of, one of, one of the, one of the great, you know,
我对各种异想天开的理论都持开放态度。你继续，继续说。你看，其中一个，其中一个，其中一个，其中一个伟大的，你知道，
the Sasanian and the Parthians developed very, uh, heavily armored, uh, mounted, what we would turn knights. Yes. You know, Dominic would like this. Dominic, you who fan aren't you because they look like cybermen they look like cybermen interesting cataphracts and the argument is is how did these these heavily armored knights with
萨珊王朝和帕提亚王朝发展出了非常重装的、骑马的，我们称之为骑士的部队。是的。你知道，多米尼克会喜欢这个。多米尼克，你是粉丝，不是吗？因为他们看起来像赛博人，他们看起来像赛博人，有趣的重装骑兵。而争论的焦点是，这些重装骑士是如何
their lances as it happens in many cases how did they sit upright on their horses yeah i mean in the sense of their their charging you You see these wonderful sort of freezes in southern Iran of knights sort of basically jousting at each other. Now, the argument is, and I've talked to a number
在很多情况下带着长矛，他们是如何在马背上坐直的？是的，我的意思是，在他们冲锋的意义上。你在伊朗南部看到了这些美妙的骑士浮雕，基本上是在互相进行长枪比武。现在，争论的焦点是，我已经和一些
of colleagues about this, they are, but, you know, they have these very sort of rigid saddles in which they sat in. But, you know, there's an argument that actually the stirrup
同事讨论过这个问题，他们是，但是，你知道，他们有那种非常僵硬的马鞍，他们坐在里面。但是，你知道，有一种观点认为实际上马镫
came from Central Asia through into Iran and the Iranians sort of basically operationalised it. So stirrups, knights, tournaments. Knights, knights, chivalry.
是从中亚传入伊朗的，伊朗人基本上将其投入了使用。所以马镫、骑士、锦标赛。骑士，骑士，骑士精神。
I mean, chivalry, I'd like to, you know, let's get into all that. I think that's quite important. I think it's very, very underrated in the West because we talk about the chanson de Roland and all this sort of stuff. But, you know, actually the epic poetry, knightly, courtly love, all this sort of stuff. I mean, there's a lot of this in Persian epic poetry. And I think that.
我的意思是，骑士精神，我想，让我们深入探讨一下。我认为这非常非常被西方低估了，因为我们谈论的是《罗兰之歌》之类的东西。但是，你知道，实际上史诗诗歌、骑士爱情，所有这些东西。我的意思是，波斯史诗诗歌中有很多这样的内容。我认为。
But in other things, I think also the Iranians are basically the founders of backgammon. Now you'll hear people say that Iranians are the founders of chess and a lot of the terms for chess come from- Chess came from India though, didn't it? It did come from India. You're absolutely right.
但在其他方面，我认为伊朗人基本上是双陆棋的创始人。现在你会听到人们说伊朗人是国际象棋的创始人，而且很多国际象棋的术语来自——但国际象棋来自印度，不是吗？它确实来自印度。你说得完全正确。
And I want to reveal my magnanimity and real impartiality there. You're giving India something. By not claiming chess, I'm sure a lot of my Iranian colleagues will berate me for that. I want to reveal my magnanimity and real impartiality there. You're giving Indians something. By not claiming chess, I'm sure a lot of my Iranian colleagues will berate me for that. But, I mean, what I would say is the Iranians probably refined the rules and made it workable. But nonetheless, I don't think we can claim that. But backgammon, I think we can claim. Backgammon, we can claim.
我想在那里展现我的宽宏大量和真正的公正。你给了印度一些东西。通过不声称拥有国际象棋，我相信我的许多伊朗同事会因此责骂我。我想在那里展现我的宽宏大量和真正的公正。你给了印度人一些东西。通过不声称拥有国际象棋，我相信我的许多伊朗同事会因此责骂我。但是，我的意思是，我想说的是，伊朗人可能改进了规则并使其可行。但尽管如此，我不认为我们可以声称拥有它。但双陆棋，我认为我们可以声称。双陆棋，我们可以声称。
And in terms of leisure and sort of food food stuffs i am going to make a bid for spaghetti now i did not see that coming yeah goodness well any italian listeners out there well i mean the argument is that uh you know marco polo never really got to china and uh he picked up a lot of these sort of ideas, you know, that these noodles, in a sense, had come during the Mongol Empire, you know, through to the Iranians refined it, as we always do, by the way, always make things better, by and large. And then he took that spaghetti back with him to Northern Italy when he returned. So there's an interesting argument, and I'm quite taken by that one. When you say it's an interesting argument, are you saying that this might conceivably be true? say when you say it's an interesting argument yeah are you
在休闲和食物方面，我现在要为意大利面争取一下。我没预料到这一点。是的，天哪。好吧，任何意大利听众，我的意思是，争论的焦点是，你知道，马可·波罗从未真正到达过中国，他吸收了很多这些想法，你知道，这些面条，在某种意义上，是在蒙古帝国时期，通过伊朗人传过来的，他们改进了它，顺便说一句，我们总是这样做，总的来说，总是让事情变得更好。然后他回到意大利北部时把意大利面带了回去。所以这是一个有趣的论点，我很喜欢这个。当你说是这是一个有趣的论点时，你是说这可能确实是真的吗？当你说是这是一个有趣的论点时，
saying that this might conceivably be true or are you saying it's true i i'm saying on spaghetti it's it's one that i would like to claim uh i think there are strong there are strong there are well i mean you know where i get into trouble in where is when we start claiming things like hummus and stuff which we can't because our lebanese friends get very upset and uh so you know but spaghetti i think you know there's a pretty strong there's a strong ali can i take you back for one second from spaghetti back to the knights yeah sure now i know we're in the middle of your top 10 so i don't want to delay you too long say are you able in about one sentence if the persians were so great and they had these
你是说这可能确实是真的，还是说它是真的？我是在说关于意大利面，这是我想声称的一个，我认为有强有力的，有强有力的，好吧，我的意思是，你知道我在哪里会遇到麻烦，那就是当我们开始声称拥有像鹰嘴豆泥之类的东西时，我们不能，因为我们的黎巴嫩朋友会非常生气，所以你知道，但意大利面，我认为，你知道，有一个相当强有力的，有一个强有力的。阿里，我能把你从意大利面拉回到骑士那里一秒钟吗？是的，当然。现在我知道我们正处于你的前十名中间，所以我不想耽误你太久。你是说，你能用大约一句话解释一下，如果波斯人那么伟大，他们有这些
fantastic saddles and whatnot why did did they lose to Alexander the Great? Ah, well, there's two things there. Two sentences only? Yeah. Those knights didn't develop until after Alexander the Great, one. Okay. But two, most of the reason why Iranian states collapse is political rather than military, very simply. It's basically divisions of command.
梦幻般的马鞍之类的东西，为什么他们输给了亚历山大大帝？啊，好吧，这里有两件事。只能两句话？是的。那些骑士直到亚历山大大帝之后才发展出来，第一。好的。但第二，伊朗国家崩溃的大部分原因主要是政治上的，而不是军事上的，很简单。基本上是指挥权的分裂。
They all busy backstabbing each other. I mean, the other thing that we do very well in Iran is decadence. I actually didn't add that in the list. But decadence is actually pretty good. I mean, we- That's a great thing to be good at, isn't it? I mean, decadence and- If I want to be known for anything, it's decadence and depravity.
他们都忙着互相背后捅刀子。我的意思是，我们在伊朗做得很好的另一件事是颓废。我实际上没有把它加到名单里。但颓废实际上相当不错。我的意思是，我们——这真是一件擅长的好事，不是吗？我的意思是，颓废和——如果我想因为什么而闻名，那就是颓废和堕落。
Of course, I mean, you know, Gibbon has this wonderful notion about, you know, because they struggled to find how to categorise the Persians, you know, they didn't want to put them in the category of barbarians. So they said, well, they're civilised, really, and they're part of the civilised world. And you see that a lot in 18th century European depictions. But Gibbon sort of basically develops this notion that the reason why the Persians aren't doing as well as they might be doing is because actually they've become over-civilised. They've done civilisation to the nth degree and therefore become decadent. And I think that's great. That's a sort of Orientalist argument, isn't it?
当然，我的意思是，你知道，吉本有一个关于这个的美妙概念，你知道，因为他们努力寻找如何对波斯人进行分类，你知道，他们不想把他们归类为野蛮人。所以他们说，好吧，他们确实是文明的，他们是文明世界的一部分。你在18世纪的欧洲描绘中经常看到这一点。但吉本基本上发展出这样一种观点：波斯人之所以表现得不如他们可能表现得那么好，是因为实际上他们变得过度文明了。他们把文明做到了极致，因此变得颓废。我认为这很棒。这是一种东方主义的论点，不是吗？
They're a feat and they're drinking sherbet and strolling in their paradise gardens. It is, yes. They do that. But it's also quite a nice idea that, you know, we're so good at civilisation, we've just overdone it. You're too good. You're too good. On the topic of being too good at civilization we just overdone it you're too good you're too good on the topic of being too good at civilization give us give us some more we're running out of time so sorry so uh the couple of other things that i would say uh there's and this is tied with the cavalry notion is the high heel which actually was news to me but it's quite that's pretty
他们软弱无力，喝着果子露，在他们的天堂花园里漫步。确实是这样。他们确实那样做。但这也是一个相当不错的想法，你知道，我们太擅长文明了，我们只是做得过头了。你们太棒了。你们太棒了。关于太擅长文明这个话题，我们只是做得过头了，你们太棒了，你们太棒了。关于太擅长文明这个话题，再给我们讲讲，我们时间不多了，所以抱歉，所以，我想说的另外几件事，这与骑兵的概念有关，是高跟鞋，这实际上对我来说是新闻，但这相当——那相当
decadent there's a couple of fashion things i would say in the 17th century if you look at the the the changes in fashion in europe between the early and the later part of the 17th century there is this this this is the point when early modern european travelers were going to iran much more often and they come back with fashion tips and a number of them if you see you know charles ii and the others all wear these rather extravagant high heels um the reason for the high heels was basically to be able to sort of sit comfortably in the saddle with the stirrup, you see. So you have these sort of bits of heels. So not to look taller?
颓废。我想说有几件时尚的事情，在17世纪，如果你看看欧洲17世纪早期和晚期时尚的变化，这是早期现代欧洲旅行者更频繁地去伊朗的时候，他们带回了时尚建议，如果你看到，你知道，查理二世和其他人，他们都穿着这些相当奢侈的高跟鞋。高跟鞋的原因基本上是为了能够舒适地坐在带有马镫的马鞍上，你看。所以你有这些鞋跟。所以不是为了看起来更高？
Not to look taller, interestingly enough. We thought it was, actually. You're quite right, because we had discussed this about all these, you know, Persians with high heels to look very tall. The other one, which, a fashion item, which I think, which I can trace fairly securely to John Evelyn's diaries, actually, in the 17th century, is the adoption of the Persian coat in the 17th century,
不是为了看起来更高，有趣的是。我们实际上以为是。你说得很对，因为我们讨论过所有这些，你知道，穿着高跟鞋看起来很高的波斯人。另一个，一个时尚单品，我认为，我可以相当确定地追溯到约翰·伊夫林的日记，实际上，在17世纪，是17世纪波斯外套的采用，
which was taken in by, yes, which was absorbed by Louis XIV's court and then, of course, adopted by other courts in Europe. And so that's ultimately the jacket, the kind of jacket you wear with the suit to this day. So basically, Persian... A sort of jacket with lapels. So that is claimed to be the Persian coat.
它被路易十四的宫廷吸收了，然后当然被欧洲的其他宫廷采用了。所以这最终就是夹克，那种你至今仍穿着西装的夹克。所以基本上，波斯……一种带翻领的夹克。所以这被声称是波斯外套。
So the Persians have invented the suit. I'm sure my, well, I mean, the trouser. The trouser is a Persian item of clothing. Yes, of course. I mean, the Greeks find that hilarious, don't they? I mean, look at those Romans in their, you know, lovely outfits, you know, very impressive. But that's the brilliant thing about the Greeks, isn't it?
所以波斯人发明了西装。我相信我的，好吧，我的意思是，裤子。裤子是波斯人的服装。是的，当然。我的意思是，希腊人觉得这很滑稽，不是吗？我的意思是，看看那些穿着可爱服装的罗马人，你知道，非常令人印象深刻。但这就是希腊人的聪明之处，不是吗？
That they thought the Persians were hilariously effeminate because they wore trousers rather than skirts. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, that's quite interesting. So these sort of items of clothing that obviously the Europeans have taken and made into their own. Frankly, I think you should be very grateful. So when you walk down the street in St. Andrews and you see people wearing coats and trousers, do you feel sort of triggered by their cultural appropriation of your... You know, as I said, I think the Persians are very giving people.
他们认为波斯人非常滑稽地女性化，因为他们穿裤子而不是裙子。是的。是的，我的意思是，这很有趣。所以这些欧洲人显然已经拿走并将其变成自己的服装。坦率地说，我认为你应该非常感激。所以当你走在圣安德鲁斯的街上，看到人们穿着外套和裤子时，你会因为他们对你的文化挪用而感到被触发吗？你知道，正如我所说，我认为波斯人是非常慷慨的人。
We think great. I just think that it would be nicer if they showed a bit more gratitude, really. Okay. That's very magnanimous of you. So, Ali, did you ever watch Goodness Gracious Me? I didn't. Well, there was a sketch with the...
我们认为很好。我只是觉得如果他们表现出多一点感激之情会更好，真的。好的。你真是太宽宏大量了。所以，阿里，你看过《Goodness Gracious Me》吗？我没看过。好吧，有一个小品，里面有……
There was a kind of Indian father talk to his son and everything's Indian. So anything that comes on the telly or anything, it's always Indian. And on the, we've talked about India in relation to chess. Could I float another topic, perhaps to add to the top 10, which is the British Raj.
有一个印度父亲和他的儿子说话，一切都是印度的。所以电视上出现的任何东西，总是印度的。关于，我们已经谈到了印度与国际象棋的关系。我可以提出另一个话题，也许可以加到前十名中，那就是英属印度。
The British Raj is actually hugely Persian. Because one of the things, one I was researching for Persian Father, the book I wrote about the Persian wars with Greece. Good plug. Very good plug. Came across it. Sip that one in very, very delicately. Was reading about Lord Curzon.
英属印度实际上非常波斯化。因为其中一件事，我在研究《波斯之父》时，那本我写的关于波斯与希腊战争的书。很好的植入。非常好的植入。偶然发现了它。非常非常巧妙地提到了那一点。是在读关于寇松勋爵的书。
Yes. Who went on a trip to Persia. That's right. And went to Persepolis, admired it hugely. And left his graffiti on there. Yes, he left his mark. Yes, as grand British lords tend to do. In due course, he then became Viceroy of India
是的。他去了一趟波斯。没错。去了波斯波利斯，非常钦佩它。并在那里留下了他的涂鸦。是的，他留下了他的印记。是的，正如伟大的英国勋爵们倾向于做的那样。后来，他成为了印度总督
and was a tremendous enthusiast for kind of Persian-style court flummery. So do you think there's a case for saying that actually, you know, the British like to think that they were, you know, they were all learning Greek in their boarding schools and things, but actually the British in India were much more Persian than they were Greek? And yes, and I'm very, very pleased you said that actually, Tom, because there's a couple of things I will outline here on the contribution of British India, which basically, as you can quite rightly say, they take over the administration from the Mughal Empire. The Mughal Empire, the administration of the Mughal Empire is basically based on Persian models. And it's actually the language is Persian. If you go out in the Indian civil service, at least till 1857, you have to learn Persian.
并且是波斯式宫廷繁文缛节的狂热爱好者。所以你认为有没有理由说，实际上，你知道，英国人喜欢认为他们是，你知道，他们在寄宿学校学习希腊语之类的，但实际上在印度的英国人比希腊人更波斯化？是的，我非常非常高兴你这么说，汤姆，因为这里有几件事我要概述一下关于英属印度的贡献，正如你非常正确地所说，他们从莫卧儿帝国接管了行政管理。莫卧儿帝国的行政管理基本上是基于波斯模式的。而且实际上语言是波斯语。如果你去印度公务员系统，至少到1857年，你必须学习波斯语。
Persian is the language of administration. It's very striking, actually. And it, you know, it hints also as to why Britain and Iran have such an interesting relationship, I should say, because in many ways, Britain was in charge for 100 years or so of at least one half of the Persianate world, if I can put it that way. Now, we derive a lot of things. And I would like to make a claim.
波斯语是行政语言。这实际上非常引人注目。而且，你知道，这也暗示了为什么英国和伊朗有如此有趣的关系，我应该说，因为在许多方面，英国在100年左右的时间里至少管理着波斯世界的一半，如果我可以这样说的话。现在，我们衍生了很多东西。我想提出一个主张。
You've tipped me off here, I'm afraid. I'm going to go for it now. I'm going to say that the modern civil service, as derived from the Indian civil service, has really borrowed a lot of its ideas and attitudes from the old traditional Persian administration. And one of my favorite terms in all this is the idea of purdah. You know, when we go in politics, all this is the idea of purdah. You know, when we go in politics, the civil service go purdah. Well, purdah is really a Persian word, pardir, which means curtain, okay, or the veil. So basically, when elections start, the civil
恐怕你已经给我提过醒了。我现在要说了。我要说的是，现代公务员制度，正如从印度公务员制度衍生而来，确实从古老的传统波斯行政管理中借鉴了很多想法和态度。在所有这些中，我最喜欢的术语之一是“普达”（purdah）的概念。你知道，当我们进入政治时，所有这些都是普达的概念。你知道，当我们进入政治时，公务员系统进入了普达。好吧，普达实际上是一个波斯词，pardir，意思是窗帘，好的，或者面纱。所以基本上，当选举开始时，公务员
service goes behind the veil, it goes into purdah. And this is a term directly derived, obviously, from the experience in British India and the Persian world. So I would agree with you. I mean, I think there's a strong case to be made that many of these ideas of the civil service and its administration that they developed as part of the East India Company, obviously, and then driven in and derived in the 19th century into the British Civil Service. I think there's a case to be made there as well. I mean, particularly given my current role. So the British Civil Service is Persian as well? Well, it's got deep roots there, I think. I mean, the Persian vizierate is pretty clear. I mean, there's strong humanist tradition. So, Tom, it's pretty clear now why they lost to Alexander the Great, right? I mean, they're a load of bureaucrats,
系统躲在面纱后面，它进入了普达。这个术语显然直接源于英属印度和波斯世界的经验。所以我同意你的观点。我的意思是，我认为有充分的理由认为，公务员制度及其行政管理的许多想法，是他们作为东印度公司的一部分发展出来的，显然，然后在19世纪被驱动并衍生到英国公务员制度中。我认为这也有理由。我的意思是，特别是考虑到我目前的角色。所以英国公务员制度也是波斯化的？好吧，我认为它在那里有深厚的根基。我的意思是，波斯维齐尔制度非常清晰。我的意思是，有强大的文人传统。所以，汤姆，现在很清楚为什么他们输给了亚历山大大帝，对吧？我的意思是，他们是一群官僚，
bureaucrats eating spaghetti in gardens with high heels. Well, as Ali said, decadent. That's a rather scathing way to look at it. I just think that, you know, the Persians were thinking, oh my God, here come these Western barbarians. I mean, what the hell are we going to do? Let's make them Persian. I mean, that's what they did.
穿着高跟鞋在花园里吃意大利面的官僚。好吧，正如阿里所说，颓废。这是一种相当尖刻的看法。我只是认为，你知道，波斯人在想，天哪，这些西方野蛮人来了。我的意思是，我们到底该怎么办？让他们波斯化吧。我的意思是，他们就是这么做的。
And it kind of worked. So Ali, I think we've almost run out. And of course, time is a Persian idea as well, isn't it? Yeah, unfortunately, time. Yes, beginning and end. That's a very personal idea. But since we invented time, we should be able to make it more flexible, surely. I mean, we have some prior, you know.
而且它奏效了。所以阿里，我想我们快没时间了。当然，时间也是一个波斯概念，不是吗？是的，不幸的是，时间。是的，开始和结束。这是一个非常个人的想法。但既然我们发明了时间，我们肯定应该能够让它更灵活。我的意思是，我们有一些先例，你知道。
I didn't mention science, which I'm sorry to say is, but there are elements of science and astronomy that would be quite important. But, you know, there you are. I think you've had gardening in high heels. You don't need science as well. That's overreaching there but is there any any last addition to that list before we before we reach the end times um i i as i said i would only say things like you know element algebra you know yeah okay yeah as algebra person rather than arabic yes yes because i mean
我没有提到科学，我很遗憾地说，但有一些科学和天文学的元素会非常重要。但是，你知道，就是这样。我想你已经有了园艺和高跟鞋。你不需要科学。那有点言过其实了，但在我们到达终点之前，名单上还有什么最后的补充吗？嗯，我，正如我所说，我只会说像，你知道，元素代数，你知道，是的，好的，是的，作为代数波斯人而不是阿拉伯人，是的，是的，因为我的意思是
the chap who was really persian i mean, that's not, you know. I mean, he might have written in Arabic, but that's... Right, that doesn't sound immensely convincing to me, but I'll let it go. Well, Ali, thank you. Thank you so much. That's fantastic. I think you've conclusively proved to everyone's satisfaction
那个真正是波斯人的家伙，我的意思是，那不是，你知道。我的意思是，他可能用阿拉伯语写作，但那是……对，这听起来对我来说不太有说服力，但我会放过它。好吧，阿里，谢谢你。非常感谢。这太棒了。我认为你已经向大家满意地证明了
that everything is Persian. And on that that note what else is there to say except thank you very much thank you ali thank you thanks for listening to the rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一切都是波斯化的。关于这一点，除了谢谢你，还有什么可说的呢？谢谢你，阿里，谢谢。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。